NARRATOR: Houston,
Texas, July 20, 1969.
At NASA Mission Control Center,
the massive IBM System/360
Model 75 computer, which
boasts processing power
of 16.6 million
instructions per second
and up to 8 megabytes
of main memory,
is employed to accomplish the
greatest feat in human history,
putting a man on the moon.
People across the
world marveled at
this technological achievement.
But incredibly, only
six decades later,
a handheld device weighing
less than half a pound
dwarfs the total technology
NASA possessed in 1969.
Today's smartphone contains
a staggering 1 million
times the computing power used
to carry out the moon landing.
What we had when
they went to the moon
is like nothing compared
to what an average teenager
carries around now.
I mean, the kind
of computing power,
the ability to
access information,
reach people, it's
an astonishing
technological achievement.
You can only
imagine what's going
to happen 30 years from now.
What we think is so advanced
is going to be so not advanced.
NARRATOR: According to
ancient-astronaut theorists,
at specific points in
history, extraterrestrials
have influenced certain
individuals to allow humanity
to make major leaps forward.
And they propose that
this has continued
up until modern times.
As evidence, they
point to the visionary
who jump-started
the microcomputer
revolution, Steve Jobs.
KARA SWISHER: Steve Jobs
was one of the greatest
visionaries in Silicon Valley.
The idea of what he was doing
is how you popularize computing.
A lot of people who
were early in computing
didn't think about
people using them,
and he managed to deliver
into the hands of consumers
a device that was usable.
It was intuitive.
It was easy to use.
It was easy to understand.
And that is not a small thing.
In the simplicity
and the beauty of it,
he made something
that was just perfect.
NARRATOR: Steve
Jobs and his team
of engineers at Apple
harnessed technology
that connected society
digitally and put
all the world's
knowledge literally
at mankind's fingertips.
But the seeds of this
technological revolution
were planted in 1973 when
the 19-year-old college
student dropped out of school.
Jobs was attending Reed
College in Portland, Oregon
when he, along with one of
Apple's first employees, Daniel
Kottke, made a decision
that would change not only
the course of their
lives but ultimately
the course of humanity.
Fueled by his desire to find
spiritual enlightenment,
Steve Jobs traveled
to India, with Daniel
following a few months later.
Together, they
discovered a Hindu
guru known as Haidakhan Baba.
He was discovered at about the
age of 18 doing yoga in a cave,
but there are legends going
back that the same figure
had appeared all the
way back into the 1800s.
NARRATOR: Haidakhan
Baba claimed that he
had no mother or father.
But who was this character
who had no known history
before the age of 18
and was said to have
manifested out of thin air?
He professed that he
was an immortal being.
LAYNE LITTLE: Steve Jobs did
spend some time with them.
Haidakhan Baba actually
gave him an initiation
by giving him a spiritual name.
This is a traditional
kind of initiation.
So they were formally
initiated by this guru.
Babaji had said that he was
a celestial being who had come
to earth to help
enlighten our planet
and to advance us forward.
And we have to
wonder, is it possible
that Steven Jobs
was being influenced
telepathically by an
extraterrestrial entity named
Babaji?